cyberpunk 2077's class action lawsuit
has reached a settlement don't remember
CD projekt Red getting sued I don't
blame you investors filed the suit
against the dev back in 2020 which
somehow feels like yesterday but also 10
years ago at the same time back then
investors claimed that cyberpunk 2077's
buggy launch date was hidden from them
thus causing them to lose money now CD
projekt Red will pay out 1.85 million to
plaintiffs this sum covers settlement
Administration costs taxes attorneys
fees and more for any investor who
purchased a CD projekt Red stock between
January 16 2020 and December 17 2020.
that is a ton of money but on the bright
side at least now CD projekt Red has
another piece of cyberpunk's rough
launch that it can put behind them the
game has been back on PlayStation for a
while now next-gen versions are out tons
of great updates and fixes have been
issued and people love the Netflix anime
things are looking good even though the
multiplayer component of the game was
scrapped in order to focus on those
fixes night City residents are still
getting the Phantom Liberty expansion
later this year this will be paid DLC
but cdpr has yet to announce a price and
while we're on the subject of game
prices Dr sir Khan Toto of Katan games
thinks the industry will see prices
increase across the board in an
interview with gi.biz the analyst said
that fans should expect price hikes for
games hardware and subscriptions as
Studios attempt to make up for Rising
costs Nintendo fans might be safe though
as Toto doesn't believe its Hardware
prices are going north of where they are
now in 2022 Sony raised the price of the
PlayStation 5 in many places around the
world but not the US in response to
Global economic issues later in the year
Microsoft announced that it is Raising
prices on its AAA games in 2023 from 60
dollars to seventy dollars all of
Microsoft's games are also included in
Xbox game and some believe that
subscription service will see a price
increase too before this Publishers like
EA Take 2 and Activision raised game
prices from 60 to 70 bucks luckily
there's still a way to get your Call of
Duty fix without shelling out the big
bucks I'm of course talking about war
zone 2. unfortunately there seems to be
a bug Shadow Banning players who are
good at the game as previously reported
by Jake Luckey on Twitter some of
Warzone 2's top Pro players and
streamers are sharing clips of getting
immediately disconnected from the game
specifically after getting their 10th
kill of the match the effective players
are also claiming that their accounts
are Shadow banned after being
disconnected meaning they are shunned
from regular lobbies and forced into war
zone 2's smaller pool of suspected
cheaters with the 10th kill being the
most common denominator players may want
to ease off the trigger after getting
Nine Kills and avoid going into those
High kill games until the issue is
sorted the issue hasn't been
acknowledged by the developer yet but
players can check their Shadow band
status and make an appeal on the
Activision support page well it's the
weekend so let me know what you're
playing this weekend and how the first
week of 2023 has been to you so far mine
was pretty good see you next week